you got your start famously on ER and  then you've been on flowing skies for a  number of years when you put it all  together it's solid great work for how  many years now 20 over 20 over 20 years  of solid work that is so uncommon in the  acting business you just have non-stop  good work all that time do your fellow  actors are they do they get jealous  sometimes that you're always working ah  jealous I had actually it was at the  upfront last year and one of the Wayans  brothers paid me I kind of I took it as  a compliment he said man you're like the  white Cosby you've been on TV forever  right and at the time it was a less  complicated maybe it was because I  called him Charlotte with Shawn or  Marlon I could have let it slip in  Charlotte sure that's nice to just mash  them together hey thanks for watching  please subscribe to my youtube channel  so they will stop making me shoot these  videos please